hey guys I'm Ryan right hey I'm Veronica
and we're gonna watch his trailer for a
movie a trailer that came out a long-ass
time ago and I'm finally getting around
to it it's called if I stay I think this
is a romantic movie I it stars Chloe
grace Moretz who is not yet a teen so I
can't talk about her but when she's 18
trust me I'm gonna be talking about her
anyway yeah I don't know anything about
this movie so let's uh let's check out
this trailer I'll be auditioning for
Juilliard
that's a serum I figured you know if you
look at it every night it won't seem so
scary when you get there
I told you be with him too you know
you know how when you meet someone and
they just already are the person they're
meant to be that was out nobody outside
Portland had ever heard of his band but
he already was somebody me not too much
she shouldn't be scared to hang out with
those guys they're us exactly Adams here
kids be careful out there here it gets
pretty wild at Symphony I have a jolly
mess of my entire life
can't hide in that rehearsal room
forever
it's too late see you
comes to me else like Here I am Nia the
girl who thinks up the cello and Adam
and just like yeah ugz my dying here's
the secret baby if you live if you die
it's all up to you for whatever fight
you got in you you gotta pull it out now
say something I'm giving up on you kids
waking up an orphan if she wakes up
sometimes you make choices in life and
sometimes choices make you
do you like me better is this see you
you are now is the same you I was in
love with yesterday the same you all be
a little bit tomorrow
life is big Frank gigantic stinking mess
that's the meteor tail I'm still here
and I'm crazy in love with you
please stay I think it would teach easy
what do you guys think I okay I'll be
honest first it was like super cheesy to
me
like hey I'm the cute little high school
guy in a band and the whole trailer
consists of I love you I love you I love
you but then I'll admit after the car
crash I was like okay this is pretty
interesting actually uh I like plots
like that I'll check it I like Chloe
grace Moretz a lot I think she's a
wonderful actress
so yeah I'll check it out I mean I'm
sure there'll be some cheesy moments
whatever but I like a little cheese
there's like a little cheese Veronica in
love with you so good I never even heard
of this movie before so I'm really
looking forward to watching this I think
that it's I think the trailer is really
great and the music I love that song and
she's gonna be impressive in this ekend
tall and it's just an awesome concept I
love it I love it so can we go watch
this movie together and can we have that
moment where I just grab your hand and
we hold it hold hands I have to think
about it she'll think about it people
most action I'll get this year well
thank you guys for recommending that
trailer like seven and a half months ago
why don't you subscribe to the real
rejects if you're interested and if
you're also interested in Veronica's
channel you could subscribe here
yeah didn't you see her boobs on her
channel it's awesome nudity is not
allowed on YouTube but she doesn't care
Veronica what you know what I want to do
right now hi I would love to do some
shout outs you one yeah do that too you
know uh there's this guy out there named
Julian Schuler Julian Schuler he saw my
Dracula untold trailer reaction and then
you know what he told me what'd he say
he said yo first-timer mind giving me a
shout on your next vid well it's not the
next one but I eventually got around to
you buddy this is your shoutout
what a beautiful day Julian Julian I
know a girl named Julian actually
gorgeous mom total milf so good stand
for Mom ID mom I'd like to anytime milf
oh don't try my Julian Oh milf mom I
like to [ __ ] yeah it's actually Sally's
boyfriend's mom appropriate I'm gonna
stop calling my older sister milf oh
she's a total milf my sister's a hi do
you Cassandra
oh you're watching girl hotties oh yeah
they're all gorgeous I'm kind of like
the black sheep so they're hot
I have fantasies where it's just us
sisters and you're off in the corner
getting jealous Julie you should
masturbate together and think about the
same okay grant said I'm not a youtuber
but can I get a shout out anyway you are
hilarious
well you don't need to be youtuber to
get a shout out you can just be you and
I want you to just be you okay gran
forgot your name already but Kay grant
you are a man and don't forget that
unless you're a girl then you are a lady
and if you're hermaphrodites whoa
you got to show me that thing down high
I would love to see that in person just
to know just so I can say I've seen your
penis vagina
Ouisa visa with a visitor please shout
out never got one a nice video always a
visa man we use the Fiza you probably
got an awesome vagina I'm gonna play the
harmonica when I think about your vagina
coming up here and I'm gonna hump you I
want to do this [ __ ] all night long to
you I want to make love I want to get
sent from above all that [ __ ] on there I
think I mean isn't shove right into your
vagina I want to do this man I want to
[ __ ] you all night long it's a right
this song it may feel right but
sometimes it may feel wrong and then
you're gonna suck on my schlong the harm
probably no I know that probably suck
you imagine how you're uncomfortable you
can make him it doesn't matter me I'm
sure he wants to suck my dick